we have a result now 52 to 48 say they  have decided to acquit Donald Trump the  Republican led Senate as was expected  has found Donald Trump not guilty of  abuse of power and obstruction of  Congress this is an historic moment in  America's history and in Donald Trump's  presidency his party have been loyally  sticking by him they believe the facts  did not constitute an impeachable  offense some among them questions the  very heart of the facts that the  Democrats put forward senators president  not having pronounced him guilty the  Senate our judges that the respondent  Donald John Trump President of the  United States is not guilty as charged  in the first article of impeachment